hi I'm Barton Seaver chef and National
Geographic fellow and this is cook wise
you
we're here in the heart of Maryland's
Eastern Shore with one of my personal
heroes dr. carl safina of the blue ocean
institute he's going to tell us about a
little fish that plays a big role what
do you got here so this is a bowl of
fish called menhaden and these fish are
really important food for a lot of other
fish pretty much any other fish that
eats fish on this coast eats menhaden
they're like the peanut butter and jelly
of the sea so this little fish does need
our protection we need to keep these
guys around yeah I think everything
needs our protection and we do have to
keep these guys around because if you
pull these out a lot of other things
would collapse let's go see some of
these fish in action
by number a lot of efficient than that
are men hating which have a lot of
different names other parts of the coast
some places they're called porgies some
places they're called pogies or bunkers
so this seems a very artisanal way to
fish what about the industrial methods
the commercial methods that target men
haters are much much larger scale they
use they use airplanes to spot the
schools which frequently travel near the
surface often in very big schools and
then they circle them with a big net
called a person and they can catch
entire schools I mean they catch many
many tons and then to get them out of
the net they have these gigantic suction
hoses that actually suck them right onto
the boat so the whole the whole scale is
very very different I mean if this is
like working in a shop that's like
working in a factory
so how can we keep the menhaden
protective how can we keep this whole
ecosystem working what's a matter of
limits and you know you don't take them
out faster than they can reproduce and
try to find out how many the bay could
hold ideally you'd want to keep the
populations just about at their capacity
and then take what you can as the the
surplus off the top of the wolf the
interest and a lot of fisheries are
depleted because people just continue to
catch them even as they were declining
until there are very few left so when we
decide how many fish to take from the
oceans we also need to decide not only
just what humans need but really what
the ecosystem needs as well well fishery
management has always been an exercise
of figuring out how many you can take
out and really what you need to figure
out is how many you have to leave in
that's the next generation Wow
now menhaden are a fish that you can
find in nearly every aisle of the
grocery store these small oily silver
fish are taken in mass from the
Chesapeake Bay and turned into products
that we use every day and for a number
of industrial uses including animal feed
which goes to feed pigs thus the pork
chops but this is pork as nature
intended and you can buy vegetarian fed
pork and poultry at most grocery stores
making small changes in our buying
habits can have a huge impact in the
health of our oceans and in this case
you can actually help save one of the
most important fish in the sea so here
we're cooking a dish where land meets
the sea grilled pork chops smothered in
Old Bay seasoning with lots of grilled
vegetables and one of my favorite
pairings with pork grilled peaches now
with these vegetables super easy I've
just taken a little bit of oil and salt
brushed them and then thrown them right
on the grill alongside the pork chops
broccoli one of my favorite things on
the grill you got to boil that and a
little bit of salted water ahead of time
and then just throw it right alongside
everything's done just about the same
time so we're gonna play it it up family
style and go serve my hungry buddy Carl
looks great I'm ready to eat now that
looks terrific but it does not look like
menhaden yeah well I cooked you
something you might actually want to eat
some vegetarian fed pork fantastic yeah
well thank you that's pleasure to have
you here and thanks for everything
you've done for me always well thank you
very much it's been a great day great
happy to be here dig in all right for
recipes tips techniques links seafood
stories and more visit us at ocean
National Geographic com backslash cook
wise to join us in a global effort to
protect the ocean visit I am the ocean
org and remember delicious is the new
environmentalism so cook wise